hi this is Thomas Lennon this is an
@midnight master class and I love wine
I'm a wine enthusiast and today I'm
going to show you just a little bit
about when you're tasting one so you're
going to press your friends at fancy
restaurants but also I thought it'd be
fun since I'm already eyeing tolded to
show you how to escape if your hands up
in zip-tied a lot of people smell corks
when they take mine people want to act
like you're fancy so they go like that
that is absolutely nothing you're never
going to really learn much from spelling
corks what you want to do a quart is a
look at it because you want to see if
it's wet the cork is dry the wine will
be positively ruined a lot of people in
the world are snobs about screw-top
lines but I'll tell you thing about a
screw top wine you will never get a
corked bottle of line with a screw top
that's where it got a really felt like
it was a reckon stinking up on me as
this was happening but it was just a
sound of the court rolled off the table
right okay so a lot of people look at
wine through you can hold it up to the
light and you're looking at what's
called the legs that means just how much
stays on the side of the glass when you
hold it up and it could you know
indicate there so I can into the wine or
a lot of sugars it's kind of like a
thick line or not doesn't necessarily
mean it's good or bad it just is what
the legs look like and then there's the
nose where you kind of smell them on I
stick my nose way in it and I smell it
really hard because I did a ton of
cocaine in the 90s so I don't have the
most amazing sense of smell a lot of
people spinning around reason you're
spinning it one it's fun to do you've
got attention deficit and it's a little
fidgety panner to it just as adding
you're getting more oxygen in the wine
and the air is you know opening it up on
letting it breathe so and then the
finish is what it tastes like on your
tongue so you kind of get air what I
always do and it looks sort of tacky but
I literally just suck air over the wine
on my tongue but if you're in a really
fancy restaurant people will assume that
you know what you're doing and they
won't think it's gross again I did a ton
of cocaine in the 90s so it's taking a
second well the other great thing about
wine as you get do this and you kind of
a smarty pants with your friends but
also getting up these are kind of rules
about lying guys I'm mostly a community
um anyway that's everything I know about
taste one uh gift guys then get
kidnapped and when you get kidnapped
somebody might zip tie your hands
together when you do what you want to do
is from way up high force of your body
I'm going to slam my hands down across
my midsection and basically use my
abdomen like a guillotine tool it just
put me out of these and they could be as
tight as they want they can be way
bigger than this two and three two one
ah that's how to get out of zip ties
that's some of the stuff I know about
wine and this is an @midnight master
class I feel like at midnight crew just
found an old napkin that's tied around
my face right now which is hilarious but
I'm also a major germaphobe
so we'll see how that it goes but I do
feel like this was just a napkin that
somebody found right